to order
and uh yes i would and i apologize to uh
to everyone for uh the technology uh
difficulties that i'm experiencing
uh as i as i was saying just before we
bring on our our
is uh the uh just here today our
subcommittee did uh through unanimous
consent
agree to a
to our subcommittee a report
which uh spells out a schedule to to
look at our pre-budget consultations our
bill c8 our emergency act as well as our
inflation
uh study and i believe the clerk has
distributed that schedule to uh to all
members there were a few minor changes
that were made to the schedule to uh
to accommodate for
of things and to actually make the disc
much much better so
the pbc
for march
3rd we'll have a second meeting from 6
to 8 pm now this is if we had consent
from all members uh to have them work
through their whips to prioritize fina
over other committees to to
allow for that meeting
uh deadline for member recommendations
submission for emergencies act study
members agreed for friday march 11th
emergency acts study members agreed to
add 30 minutes to one hour to the last
witness meeting
an emergency act study
tabling moved to monday march 28th
also uh shuffling the march uh 24th with
the 21st to help out the the analysts to
give them more time
for uh for that report
uh to have the rcmp and fintrac uh this
thursday uh come before us
and uh to have the bankers association
uh and uh looking at the also uh
desjardins and the big five banks to uh
see if they can come before our
committee on
march 7th so clerk did i capture
everything
yes sir that is my understanding unless
uh
there's a member that heard something
differently
okay
if you can just let me know if there's
any uh show of hands for that and then
what i'm asking members uh to uh for the
adoption of this report
you're getting thumbs up
yep you're getting thumbs up
excellent okay thank you thank you very
much members that is that's very helpful
and now it's uh it's my pleasure and
opportunity to welcome our witnesses
uh we have the canada revenue agency uh
sophie amber director review and
analysts division uh charities
directorate the department of finance
isabel jacques
assistant deputy minister financial
sector policy branch
uh julian brazo director general
financial crimes and security division
financial sector policy branch
manuel de so
senior director of framework
policy financial institutions division
financial sector policy branch and from
the department of justice samantha
maisland dixon
assistant deputy minister public safety
defense and immigration
portfolio
and so we will will commence with the
canada revenue agency for up to uh to
five minutes
hello hi good afternoon mr chair thank
you for the invitation to appear before
you today my name is sophie amberg and i
am the director of the review and
analysis division of the charities
directorate within the canada revenue
agency
through the clerk the cra has provided a
copy of my full remarks
to the committee's attention which
provide an overview of the cra specific
role in this area so in the interest of
time mr chair i will summarize my
remarks by noting that the cra's
contribution is administered by two
distinct areas through the charities
directorate the area that i represent
which has a particular focus on
determining whether the charitable
registration system is being abused
and through the criminal investigations
directorate which supports anti-money
laundering efforts with that mr chair
would be pleased to answer any questions
the committee may have
thank you for uh for your opening
remarks and uh clerk did you say that we
had opening runs from some of the other
witnesses
no there are none
there are no further uh further remarks
okay so we will move to uh to members
and uh
i guess i'm just looking to see
i've got
it's uh i put mp lawrence uh from the
conservative each party will have up to
uh six minutes uh for
their questions in this first round and
i've got the conservatives and p
lawrence up for six minutes
thank you mr chair and thank you for
fighting through your technological
difficulties uh we've all experienced
that throughout the co throughout the
pandemic there um i want to uh start
with a general statement and i will
welcome anyone who wishes to respond i
suspect that it's the department of
finance that would be best positioned
but uh if anyone from uh the witnesses
wants to respond that is great
the invocation of the emergency measures
act has has given government the right
to freeze the bank accounts of
individuals exposing individuals to
potential financial ruin
for as the minister of justice said
supporting causes the government does
not believe acceptable when you free
someone's bank account you are
effectively removing them from society
they may not be able to pay for food to
feed their children put gas in their car
to go to work or even
even
to pay for electricity to heat their
homes
i want to walk through i want to walk
through step by step
the emergency measures orders respecting
the financial provisions so that
canadians can clearly understand the
financial implications because i believe
there's a great deal of misinformation
out there right now
so we'll start here so uh pursuant to
the emergency measures order financial
institutions can effectively de-bank
someone as a as a designated person
under the emergency measures regulations
a designated person is defined as anyone
who has participated or supported an
unlawful assembly this gives the
government incredibly broad powers as
professor paul david said the debanking
provisions were so are so broad that
literally a clerk at a quickie mark who
sold a propane canister to a protester
could have his accounts frozen
witnesses
members
canadians are afraid
members of parliament have received
thousands of calls and emails from
canadians who are concerned that even a
small contribution to a then legal cause
could result in their financial ruin i'm
going to ask you i'm going to ask the
witnesses some clear
some clear and succinct questions i
would very much
uh appreciate their response not for me
but for the rest of canada
to the witnesses
what
what specific acts
could have or would result in the
freezing of a bank count
i apologize mr chair
what would lead to the freezing of a
bank account
under the
order that was that came into force on
february 15th would be if someone
is funding directly and or indirectly
illegal activities as they are set out
uh in the regulations that came into
force
so for example if somebody
uh was
you know
giving money
uh to a third party to enable them to
participate in the illegal blockades
that were occurring on the hill
that person could be captured
so to be clear
if a passerby gave an individual
a cup of coffee
a
they could be have their bank account
frozen
no
no not a cup of coffee
i mean we had a process in place as you
may know
the rcmp there were two the process had
two prong the first one was our
colleagues in the rcmp at list of
individuals
and were shared with the financial
institutions so that's one way in which
those individuals could be captured the
other one is if a financial institution
using their algorithm
found that there were any issues and
further to verification found out that
they were involved in so so
so my apologies i don't i don't mean to
rude but my time is short there so but
just just to be clear a a find a
financial contribution um to
to
either through a crowdsourced platform
or directly could result in their bank
account be it frozen
yes good to the yes so they didn't have
to the extent
they didn't have to actively they did
not have to actually be involved in the
protest they didn't have to be here in
ottawa or at one of the blockades
no not themselves it could be indirectly
so if someone gave twenty dollars to the
freedom convoy through a crowdsourcing
platform they could have their bank
account frozen
if that person gave the money after
february 15th it is possible although
very unlikely in view of the
circumstances and i say this because
the banks the financial institution
relied heavily on the information that
was provided by the rcmp
further to their own internal processes
and verification
and so they approach it from a basically
a risk based approach
i would
although not impossible that someone who
gave twenty dollars be captured and have
their bank account frozen
i found that scenario
you know i think it would be in rare
circumstances
but it it is possible um
so the to my mind the order is fairly
fairly clear there are some caveats on
it but it says for an assembly
and the assemblies have now been
disbanded have we stopped freezing bank
accounts
yes we have and as a matter of fact
and i don't know if this information has
been shared with a member of the
committee but yesterday and i may want
to leave the rcmp speak to this i don't
know if they're coming before you but
they did share a list
with financial institutions and
financial institutions are in freezing
accounts as of yesterday they started
yesterday to freeze accounts
and how just following up on that and
thank you for sharing that information
following up on that if you are if you
are an individual and you want your
account unfrozen
how do they appeal who they talk to
whether it might have been frozen by
mistake or or or uh in accordance with
the act
yes
so
jewels who've account have been frozen
whether mistakenly but i haven't heard
of any such incidents to contact
directly their
their banks customer service to do a
first verification
and if the bank didn't feel it had the
proper answer could reach out to the
rcmp to validate some of the information
thank you thank you mp lawrence that's
the time we are moving to the liberals
and pete zero wits for uh six minutes
please
uh thank you so much mr chair and i want
to thank all the witnesses for being
with us today on such short notice and
thank you so much for the important work
that you do
um
my first question just because i think
that just for those who are listening i
think we should just establish
uh that
when the emergencies act was declared
uh and it we announced the declaration
of a public order emergency under the
emergencies act and the disruptions the
border blockades and the occupation of
ottawa's downtown core
and under that public order emergency
there were a series of measures around
um stopping the flow of money that might
actually be funding uh any of these
public order
measures uh and events that we're taking
apart across our country
and perhaps uh directing to the
department of finance
can you give us a brief rundown of what
the
proceeds of crime and so crime money
laundering and terrorist financing act
what it allows for and what gaps
it has that the invocation of the
emergency act addresses
yes mr chair thank you for the question
so
we realized that there were gaps in the
of
system as to what our colleague at the
financial transaction and report
analysis center of canada fintrac could
capture
we realized that
it didn't capture
crowdfunding platforms not all of them
and payment service providers so when
the order came into force
crowd funding um
platforms and payment service provider
had to register with fintrac and report
any suspicious transaction to fintrac
this was in order to help mitigate
uh that these platforms
received illicit funds and increased the
quality and quantity of intelligence
received by fintrac and also
that allowed to make more information uh
available to support investigations by
law enforcement
okay thank you so just uh in in
layperson speak basically
cryptocurrencies and crowdfunding
platforms were not included under um
the uh the proceeds of crime and
terrorism financing act and so that's
that was what was put into place in
terms of emergency orders is that
correct
cryptocurrencies were
already covered although what was not
covered is the reporting by uh
crowdfunding platforms uh and uh
uh
payment service providers
and i don't know if my colleague julie
may want to add to this uh
question julian brazoo just very quickly
okay i don't see anything so happy there
okay yes i don't see him there okay my
next question is can you confirm that
making these powers permanent cannot be
done uni
unilaterally and would require
legislation
to make these permanent we have two
options we can do it by way of
legislation which includes regulations
so we can make these permanent by way of
regulations
thank you and can you also confirm that
the powers are not retroactive and it
only began after
the emergencies act was declared
yes uh i can confirm that it is not
retroactive we received many questions
from concerned
uh individuals who thought that it was
it would retroactively apply but it does
not
okay thank you um
and um we saw reports of truckers
leaving the convoy voluntarily after
being warned by their insurance
companies that their insurance may be
suspended
uh was the intent of the program
um was this the intent of the program
and do you have any further information
on the success of these measures
well
certainly the intent of the program was
to certainly
responsibilities
and dissuade people from using money or
their vehicle to participate in these
illegal blockades
i do not know if any uh
trucker or individual at their insurance
uh
suspended
uh i think the goal was to ensure that
people left on their own volition
firstly
okay
so but would you so you wouldn't know
whether or not there was an influence of
the fact that
um
that you know their insurance they could
lose their insurance that that had an
impact on the on them actually i
certainly think it it it did
i mean a lot of these people that were
involved i mean uh trucking is their
livelihood so uh to understand that your
uh insurance could be suspended i think
uh would be an incentive to uh
stop the illegal uh behaviors
and then just maybe one final one
clarification my final minute my
understanding is that government
actually has a limited role in terms of
acting really it's enabling this
information uh to be shared with
financial institutions in rcmp fun
from fintrac in order for them to have a
rolled in force
pardon me i
could not hear clearly your question
would you mind repeating please
that's okay
of course
with the these emergency measures uh in
place the in particular as it relates to
what we're currently talking about
the federal government has a limited
role in terms of enforcing it really is
enabling rcmp and financial institutions
to receive information from fintrac in
order for them to actually enforce and
take action
that that is correct privacy uh was uh
of course in the for and of concern we
want to respect the privacy of inju
individual
uh and respect the privacy act so the
order allowed for information to flow
from the rcmp and some institution
directly to the financial institutions
so not through the department of finance
that is correct thank you so much thank
you and thank you mp zerowitz and now we
are moving to the block and uh monsieur
samari for uh for six minutes
thank you cheer and i too would like to
welcome all the public officials who are
here today and thank you for all of the
efforts in these exceptional
circumstances i have a first question
for the department of finance really for
madame jacques
the
order
does not give many details about the
mechanics and the criteria for
freezing funds when we read the order
there's not many details so have you
communicated more specific details to
the financial institutions
certainly
as soon as the order entered into force
we took measures to communicate on a
regular basis with the financial
institutions
and some of our discussions on a daily
basis to make sure we can help them to
implement the order and to answer their
questions
thank you so you've talked about
discussions have you actually
sent written criteria to the financial
institutions so that they can correctly
implement these possible freezing of
funds
no is the answer we haven't sent details
or written information
but we have made ourselves available to
answer any questions that may come up
from the various
entities about implementation
moreover
we will indirectly the rcmp shared
information directly with the
institutions
so that they were able to
implement the
order now obviously
i'm very worried about the government's
action on this
if i've understood correct there's been
no written passing of criteria it's just
been on a verbal basis that then leads
to lots of possible different
interpretations we know the order gives
immunity to financial institutions
but afterwards
if the criteria just passed on verbally
during discussions that does lead to
differing interpretations
and of course for me that is problematic
i'd like to come back to that a bit
later but for the moment i'd like to
talk about vehicle insurance
has there been any written advice that's
been sent to the intruders
for this question of suspending
vehicle insurance
no
no written advice has been sent to the
insurance companies
okay so from my point of view
once again there's a problem in terms of
the government
perhaps i could clarify here the way in
which the order has been
drafted means that it's the entities
that are responsible for implementing
the order
so factually speaking
the entities were responsible to ensure
that they meet the requirements
set out in this order we answered their
questions we made ourselves available to
them but they also consulted their own
legal departments to make sure that they
were meeting the
requirements laid out in the order yes i
do understand that thank you for those
specifications but that causes an
enormous problem for me because it's
vague in the order and it's open to
interpretation if we don't add written
specific advice there's a risk of
derailment for example which advice did
you give them about insurance to ensure
that truckers were able to leave without
their license being suspended
you suggest did you suggest them you
wouldn't suspend the license while they
were leaving no i didn't suggest
anything i'm with the department of
finance
the information
was given by our rcmp colleagues they
are the ones that had certain
information that they shared with the
entities that were implementing the
order so the department of finance was
not part of that exchange of information
but to come back to the insurance
companies
if they got information and i can't
validate that
it would be up to them to decide
whether the holders of license were
actually in violation
my concern here is the implementation of
this if the trucker was leaving with his
truck
and in order to
leave the convoy he's no longer insured
if he caused an accident then the order
would actually penalize the potential
victims of that accident we've got the
no fault in quebec at least with the
saaq but interior you don't have that
so with the order i do think it could
very much penalize victims
and then i've got a that was a comment
and i'm going to go on to a question
in quebec we've got the saaq
and it's a universal and it's a
government run
and is the saeq also covered by this
federal order
the saq is not covered as such
because it's a an insurer as well even
if it's a government insurer
yes the insurers that are covered by the
order
had to take
action if they knew that a vehicle for
example was being used
in order
to participate in legal blockades or
those
assemblies that took place
and thus
they
had to suspend they had the information
and they had to suspend the insurance of
the truck because i don't know if that's
happened or not but i can let you know
that by sharing the information
there were would have been no sent to
the truckers if their insurance was
suspended uh in order to allow them to
leave there were many notices that were
given to the truckers by the rcmpt it's
time to leave now understand
how did insurers know
that they were insuring a trucker that
was there was it the rcmp that sent them
a message and asked them to suspend the
insurance well i can only believe that
if there was an exchange of information
that would no that have come from the
rcmp
but i would prefer to leave it up to the
rcmp to show the responsibility to
answer that question because the
department of finance was not
involved
at that stage in the process
thank you very much mr samari
and now we're moving to the mvp and mp
blakey for six minutes
thank you so maybe just following up
along that same line of question
um whether it's for insurance companies
or for
financial institutions more generally
what are the sources of information that
they
might have had we know the rcmp is one
source of information what would be
other sources of information under the
powers granted that they could
uh action any kind of freezing of
accounts or suspension of insurance on
yes uh
as i was mentioning so it was either as
you just mentioned through the rcmp but
they could also use
internal information using their
software their algorithm to see whether
there was any activities that were
related to these blockades but we're not
privy to what they found and and they
would vet the information and i'm sure
if they had questions they could
uh
have maybe contact with the rcmp and the
decision was theirs to make if they
wanted to freeze the account
okay
and so
when that happens are people notified
that their
that that a freezing of an account
that's occurred in their case is a
consequence
of uh the mandate under the emergencies
act
i don't know whether the financial
institutions uh advise their clients i'm
not sure if anything was posted but
certainly
i believe in the media it was clear
that this was an
imp potential impact should somebody
want to finance
illegal activities
so certainly you know i do think it was
probably communicated in advance that
this could happen but i mean in the
event that it does happen
are people told that that their account
is frozen as a consequence
of uh
the emergency orders or
are they left to wonder what right do
people have to know
whether uh what's happening to them as a
consequence of emergency orders or
whether it's happening under some other
kind of authority
yes i
oh i do not know if any such notice were
provided so if somebody's account is
suspended whether because of the order
or other reasons or other court orders
as we know the spiri ontario superior
court also
uh
issued an order to freeze accounts so as
to whether an individual would know why
their account was frozen i do not know
if any notices were provided i'm not
okay so there's no obligation to provide
such a notice
from the government or the emergency
orders
if there were it would be a result of
the internal policy of the organization
that froze the account or suspended the
insurance that is accurate okay
is it possible for government to require
financial institutions who have frozen
accounts under these authorities to
to require
those institutions to offer such a
notice
i i presume it could it could be done
legislatively i may want to turn to my
colleague manuel uh i've not done that
research i don't know if there's any
specif
more specific answer that uh manuel
jusso can provide in this regard
um well it it's just thank you for your
question it's just an initial reaction i
agree it might be possible but it's
something we would have to look at
okay i mean i think that the public
interest value and that kind of policy
would be
that there does seem to be confusion
about why some people's accounts are
being frozen right now there does seem
there's the appearance that
some folks
feel that their accounts are being
frozen as a result of the emergency
orders
uh in some cases that does not cohere
with what we're hearing from government
the requirement that when those accounts
are frozen as a cleanse of
the institutions
fulfilling their obligations under the
emergency orders
that would help people know in a very
kind of crystal clear way
whether the emergency orders
resulted in their account being frozen
or whether it was something else
so i do think that's
something for us to be considering as a
committee and for
what i hope that officials might
consider taking back to government
because that's one relatively
straightforward way that i think we
could provide a lot of clarity for
canadians who are wondering i am curious
to know what the smallest denomination
of donation
uh or contribution has resulted in a
freezing of an account so far
i would not be able to provide you that
answer uh the information was strictly
exchanged between uh law enforcement the
rcmp and the banks
is that something that would be
reasonable to expect the rcmp to know
well i mean if the rcmp exchange
information with a bank as you saw under
uh section five of the order there was a
duty to disclose to the rcmp or csis i
do not know if they have the details of
the amounts i was not privy to the
information that was shared
so
i do not know the answer to that
question
okay
um
i'm looking to the chair just to know
how i'm doing in terms of time about a
minute just under a minute
okay
so we would be looking to the rcmp for
information on how
how low
the threshold is
i mean
i think there are two
seems to me that there are maybe two
elements to the financial measures here
and i'm interested
for your input on this one clearly was
before the streets in ottawa were
cleared um
this was meant to
create a tool to put pressure on people
to leave the the the occupied area uh
and and to and to go home
um
is that the only purpose of the
financial measures or is there also some
follow-up around some of the organizers
and groups and activities that they may
have been involved in that represent a
more ongoing threat to national security
short answer please
from my perspective
uh it was solely to ensure that people
uh stop funding illegal activities
thank you
and uh thank you mp blakey we are moving
to our second round numbers uh in this
round we're starting with the
conservatives and i have np chambers up
for five minutes
thank you very much mr chair thank you
to our witnesses and uh thank you for
your answers thus far i think my
colleagues have asked some excellent
questions with respect to process so i
would like to continue to focus
on process
um can you provide the committee with a
number of how many accounts and
individuals have been frozen to date
all i provide you is uh yes in aggregate
so it would be over 206 accounts uh but
i would not be able to tell you exactly
how many entities so it's possible that
one person or one company had more than
one account
so i think we're close to yeah it's
about
maybe over 206 210. okay thank you and
so that that also confirms the next
question which is an individual could
have more than one account affected so
it could be a savings account a
checkings account or a mortgage
additional products that a financial
institution would provide okay that is
accurate
and i've heard uh
some discussion here today but also in
the media this notion the banks make a
final determination a financial
institution makes a final determination
as to whether an account is frozen
and
uh they liaise directly with the rcmp or
some other sources that is that correct
that is correct yes okay
are you aware of any circumstances
where a financial institution has
provided
um
evidence
from the rcmp or other sources
where the bank has not frozen the
account
do not know that's not the any we would
not receive that information okay
um
prior to an account being frozen i'd
like to pick up on my uh colleague mr
blakey's line um prior to an account
being frozen
are you aware of an opportunity for an
individual to either be notified or to
make any representations to the
financial institution or
law enforcement
no not to my knowledge so i
not under this order
okay
so i hope you can help me understand
one of the things we've been told about
this act is that it complies with the
charter
and
saying something complies with the
charter doesn't necessarily make it true
it's in the preamble of the emergencies
act
but the ability for
a financial institution which by the way
is a third
party
to act as the judge and the jury without
the opportunity for an individual to
make any representation i'm having a
hard time understanding how that is
compliant with the charter
i i understand your question and i i
will give a partial answer and maybe
turn to my justice colleague
this uh this was considered when the
order was drafted and that is why you
will see
uh under section 3 duty to
determine what was inserted in the order
was an obligation to the entity
financial entities to determine on a
continuing basis whether they are in
possession or control of property that
is own held control
buyer on behalf of a designated person
that section was inserted
specifically for that purpose to to be
complying with the charter and provide
uh an ensure that financial financial
institution review on an ongoing basis
so let's suppose that your bank account
was frozen
you're the wrong person you were not
involved you you have the opportunity to
go to your institution say you know or
me
not i'm not involved in the illegal
activities i did not finance
uh any activities and i need to be my
account was frozen by mistake so you had
the opportunity to do that okay
i respect that answer but just we're
short on time yes um
with respect to due process i mean that
that is not like prior to a
determination being made i mean there's
no opportunity for an individual to
provide any representation i mean to me
is a violation of the charter and due
process
the second question would be has there
been any
uh information or direction given to
financial institutions about what
information and how long they can keep
information on file on these individuals
on the information piece not to my
knowledge but the information was shared
for the financial institution to make a
determination but on the charter issue
and again i may want to turn to my
colleague justice colleague but one
need to remember that these are
extraordinary measures
they are temporary
uh in time correct correct
the behavior stops so i apologize if the
behavior stops then the there was an
obligation upon review to unfreeze the
account
thank you thank you and that is that's
the time empty chambers we are moving to
the liberals and mp baker for five
minutes please
thank you chair
can you hear me cheer
yeah i'm having some technical
difficulties so if i cut out i apologize
but that's why it would be happening
it's from some members
um
that there have been
freezes on individual bank accounts
for merely
donating or
you know purchasing merchandise for the
blockades
the rcmp actually put out a statement i
think in part to kind of clarify
this issue and i'll just read it it's
very brief this is yesterday
under the emergency economic measures
order emergencies act the list that was
provided to financial institutions
including identities of individuals who
were influencers in the illegal protest
in ottawa and owners and or drivers of
vehicles who did not want to leave the
area impacted by the protest
at no time did we provide a list of
donors to financial institutions
we are now working with the banks to
build a process to address the counts
that were frozen
so i think i thought that's important to
clarify because that you know the rcp is
trying to clarify their who the who are
the individuals on that list that
they've provided in instant financial
institutions and again they're saying
they're influencers in the illegal
protests and owners and or drivers of
vehicles who did not want to leave the
area i think it's important because it
speaks to the scope of who's being
targeted
by these uh by the rcmp's list who's on
the rcmp's list and therefore who's
being targeted by the by the financial
institutions um
could you clarify so my question is
could you clarify
um
uh when the measures were implemented
and whether or not they apply
retroactively
thank you the measures were implemented
on february 15 and they do not apply
retroactively so going to your example
and understanding the information that
was shared by the airship by the rcmp
with the financial institutions
i i must admit and based on the
knowledge that i have
i think it would be unlikely that
someone who gave and i can't imagine
certainly someone who gave twenty
dollars
three weeks ago
or even twenty dollars post february 15
that they would have been captured by a
freeze it's not impossible in view of
the order but in view of the exchange of
information and the
the focused approach
uh that was taken to uh
stop the illegal funding of these
activities uh
it would appear to be unlikely that this
occurred but not impossible
yeah
and and could you speak to your earlier
answering question from another member
about the number of accounts that have
been frozen um could you repeat that for
us how many accounts we're talking about
and if and if you have that information
because they're having public reports on
this is the amount of money that's
involved
yes uh and as you may know i mean that
that information has has flown over time
and now that uh banks are on freezing
accounts it may not be accurate and i do
not have
uh additional information so the numbers
must be lower today as we speak but to
my knowledge it's over i would say over
206 accounts and the total value the
latest number i have was seven
approximately 7.8 million
okay
so
you know if i took that 7.8 million
and i divided it by the 200 accounts you
know roughly and i'm doing this on the
top of my head uh this is this sounds
like about
an average of 35 000 dollars am i in the
ballpark
i'm not even able to well if you do that
math yes but i'm able to tell you
individually we got we received only
total amounts the department of finance
did not get you know we know that those
accounts are
uh
a personal and commercial account so
it's a mixture of the two
you know and and one person may have
more than one account so it could be
that you know
close to
you know 60 let's say entities with a
certain number of account accounts and
different products that they have so i'm
not able to tell you even the value
understood i think i have about 30
seconds left
mr jacques so i'll just ask you
did banks and financial institutions
have the ability to freeze accounts
before the emergencies act was invoked
and if so
under what circumstances yes uh on an
ongoing basis banks certainly can freeze
accounts if they are concerned that
there's fraud or illegal activities and
as you know on an ongoing basis uh
the police officers rcmp may be in
contact with banks and they take
measures sometimes to protect consumers
they freeze the accounts if they see
some
normal activities in the bank account
also as we mentioned there are other
court orders that were issued by the
provincial
courts so it's possible that they were
also uh freeze that occurred
independently of the actions under the
order thank you thank you thank you mp
baker we are moving to the block
democracy
thank you cheer
ms jack
i understand there was no written
government directive that was sent to
the financial institutions to indicate
what needed to be blocked or authorized
they were just
verbal instructions given
now verbally speaking did the government
transmit instructions
about joint accounts uh alimony are
rental heating costs etc
we fixed money
there were no written instructions
but what was
shared and once again i think you need
to ask the rcmp i know they shared
lists
with a certain amount of
information these lists were shared with
the financial institutions in writing in
terms of joint accounts absolutely it's
possible there were questions about this
if there's a person who's
involved
in the illegal blockades on
the hill
then it's very possible that a joint
account was suspended
thank you
so according to knowledge has the
government borne that in mind if the
joint account is blocked that means that
there could be a victim involved who
hadn't actually committed a
reprehensible act i understand what
you're saying and it can seem
to be a bit severe
but it was a simple solution
the person just had to stop
participating
in these illegal
activities uh as described in the order
so the
suspension was quite rapid
and for uh alumni or custody payments
the government didn't send
instructions was it the rcmp that
decided to interpret these
instructions no that's not what i wanted
to see obviously the rcmp possessed
information about the individuals and
entities that were participating in the
illegal blockades so that was the
information that was shared with the
banks
so for uh
child support payments they just said
will freeze they can't and
they cannot pay the money for example to
the mother of the child and the
government didn't decide to actually
execute
the details of this order one this
specific question we had discussions
with banks and of course they were able
to exercise their judgment to make sure
that these
child support payments considered to
continue so there was a non-viral
directive that was emitted by the
government no it wasn't directive but
there was certainly a discussion on this
okay thank you very much
thank you and mp blakey for two and a
half minutes
um
jacques you've said a couple times now
um and you can correct me if i'm wrong
but that
the the accounts were frozen and the
goal was to
stop participation in the occupation
in ottawa
or on blockades and when that
and when that behavior ceased the
accounts would be unfrozen
so financial institutions presumably
receive
information from the rcmp and on that
basis for those accounts what's the
process
for
financial institutions knowing whether
the behavior that's the subject of the
order has ceased or not
well likewise the reverse with is true
information and again i should turn to
my colleagues at the rcmp i don't want
to misspeak on their behalf but
information was shared
by the rcmp with financial institutions
and we were informed yesterday by
financial institutions that they were
unfreezing the accounts
okay so at the moment
you know subject to the time it takes to
implement that order there should be no
accounts frozen under the emergency
order
uh i would i i don't know that there is
none unless you know the the in
financial institution at different
information other than what was shared
by the rcmp and i'm not able to tell you
but i would think that the vast majority
of accounts are in the process of being
unfrozen
okay and it's subject to any new
information that the rcmp may have but
to my knowledge
that's the status of the situation
actually
okay would there be any other law
enforcement agencies that are contacting
financial institutions directly with
intelligence on whether people are
behaving in ways prohibited by by the
order so whether that's csis or local
law enforcement in in ottawa or other
places where there were blockades it's
certainly possible it's prescribed by
section 6 disclosure of information for
provincial territorial institution to
disclose
information
i do not know and i'm not able to tell
you whether any of uh
if there was any communication between
those
provincial or other
uh institution with the uh with the
financial institutions
so if other law enf like if law
enforcement agencies other than the rcmp
were communicating with financial
institutions there's no obligation to
inform the federal government that that
kind of reporting has occurred
well as you saw under section 5
the entities must disclose without delay
to the commissioner of the rcmp so the
information would come back but i think
so
your expectation would be that that
information would be captured in the
rcmp reporting
yes that would be my expectation
thank you and that is the diamond people
like you thanks we are moving to the
conservatives for five minutes mp
stewart uh you have the floor
thank you mr sheriff can you hear me
can you hear me
yes yes okay thank you
um so i mean what we're seeing here is a
complete suspension
of civil liberties number one
and the prime minister often talks about
how
which things are acceptable to him and
which things are
obviously
every other protest that blocked off a
road or a trade was acceptable
because he didn't follow the money on
any of those whether they be
climate crisis protests or for any of
those ones that he obviously supported
but he's willing to suspend civil
liberties and put canadians lives
uh and freeze their lives and put their
banks on hold right now because
single mothers and little old ladies and
lots of people in canada supported this
rightly or wrongly so
now i want to know something um
is it is it i thought i heard that this
wasn't
that it was not retroactive
are these bank seizures retroactive
could you precise what you mean by that
i mean no the order is not retroactive
so they could not use the fact that a
person gave fifty dollars
five weeks ago
to
freeze the accounts
so how what's the first date that
somebody donated to this house
pardon me what is the first date that a
person donated i i would not have the
information all i can that's interesting
because we have cra in the department of
justice the department of finance
we're suspending civil liberties and you
don't have the information no what i
mean is the first effective date of the
order was february 15th
so
a financial institutions could not have
uh
used
information obtained you know
previously
to freeze accounts but i will turn to my
colleagues no i have another question
okay there was there was one individual
in in my province that donated
uh quite a sum of money i believe um
like 75 000 or something like that so if
if that individual donated that money
say
three weeks ago
um what happens to that money and where
does it go
so
i do not know where he donated the money
uh but if the money was under i i he
donated the money your your constitution
i don't know where to which entity gave
the money but let's say that it ended up
in the financial system and that a bank
could freeze the account of the person
that's it's a person
company i don't know that received the
fundings then
it would have been frozen if captured
and now that the activities have stopped
would be
unfrozen
um
and remain in the account it wouldn't go
anywhere else it stays the question was
my question was if somebody donated
money before the 15th of february yes
what happens to it
it's it should be where the person gave
it i mean it shouldn't have been
captured and where does it go does it go
back to the person where did that person
gave the money who did he give it to i
have no idea i just see it in the
newspaper i mean let's say it was
gofundme let's say somebody made a
gofundme donation okay let's face it no
let me keep talking yes
you can make a donation to gofundme from
anywhere in the world so long as you
have a visa or a mastercard or something
that's my understanding
so let's say somebody made a donation
i don't know february the 7th or
something where did that money go
if that person to take your example gave
it to gofundme it went to the gofundme
fund and as you may know i mean from the
from the news and that i read
they returned the money back to the
donors uh on their own it the actions
gofundme took was i believe their own as
they
may not have been comfortable with uh
the ongoing activities but i'm not the
expert and i don't have
uh first-hand information but i see that
colleagues have their hands on yeah i
have another question though point of
order mr chair yeah i was gonna do that
yeah sorry to interrupt my honorable
colleague i'm just wondering
you're not pointing
point of order
go ahead i would like to ask the clerk
to ask the interpreters if the
interpretation is coming through because
it's not coming through very clearly
this is a small tactic because they
don't like the questions
mr stewart uh if we can clerk if we can
ask the interpreters
well this trick in the book isn't it is
is mr stewart coming through uh do you
need more you need more audio from mr
stewart is that what i'm getting from
the interpreters
yes yes okay so more audio from mr
stewart please for the interpreters
okay so if we could uh just uh if we
could slow down the pace mp stewart in
terms of the questions and uh how much
time just crosstalk to help the internet
you you have right now 22 seconds i did
stop the time thank you i just wanted to
say that the canadian government gave a
settlement to omer cotter 10.5 million
dollars who shot and killed our allies
in the united states trudeau said that
we can't water down canadian citizenship
a canadian is canadian as a canadian but
now we're picking point of order
point of order what point of order of
order
yes point of order yeah
relevance at the end there's many uh
instances where one could have called
point of order the uh our colleague was
interrupting the
uh the witness from answering uh
held off because it seemed to have been
corrected
but at this point especially how it's
relevant to the topic at hand
really is is beyond me
we will stick to the emergency measures
i'd like to add
something to this for some meetings now
certain mps
raise a point of order to see that the
other mp is out of order and normally in
the chamber in the committee we have
quite a lot of
flexibility
and we have to
allow them to
come up with two sentences to arrive at
the subject otherwise we're not able to
have a real debate so do make sure that
when there's this point of order to see
that uh our colleague is off topic
please let them talk and give them a bit
more room for maneuvering latitude
because there's no point systematically
interrupting the debate on this subject
thank you
merci and peace out muddy thank you and
peace
uh we were well over the time than with
uh with mr stewart so uh but uh but i
take your point we are moving now to uh
the liberals and mp chateau for five
minutes
thank you very much
cheer and thank you too
to the witnesses who have come before us
today
and thank you for your very clear
answers
i just want to ensure that i've quite uh
grasped the question uh from
mr stewart it was very interesting he
was asking
about the funds that went to go fund me
that were paid before the 15th february
what happens with these funds and i
think
the answer was also quite clear
in the media we've read that gofundme
was going to return the money directly
to the donors so thank you very much for
that answer now turning to ms jack once
again
you're giving very specific answers to
these questions and it's very much
appreciated by the committee
we've talked about rendering certain
measures
on a more permanent footing
compared or rather allowing fintrac to
be able to
receive information about certain
payment service providers that have been
used
but
in
the
money laundering and proceeds of crime
act we know already that certain banks
and financial institutions are already
obliged to make declarations and to
report to fintrac
and the emergency order are now inviting
the crowd funding
platforms and payment service providers
to also report to fintrac so can you can
confirm that if we want to
fill this legal vacuum that existed
beforehand how are we actually going to
do this exactly
can we use legislative means
as we've done
since the year 2000 of when the
anti-money laundering and proceeds of
crime act
and can we fill this legal vacuum i was
surprised to see that we had this vacuum
i think we filled some of this vacuum in
2018 when it comes to crypto currencies
they're now covered but now it does seem
that the crowdfunding platforms are
being used for illegal purposes so if we
could have your answer on that now
please
yes we've worked very closely with our
colleagues in the justice
department and we can actually do this
by
legislation uh to fill that legal vacuum
on a permanent basis or by regulation
and we're working on that for the moment
to ensure that we can fill in this gap
of to cover the crowd funding platforms
and the payment service provider so we
can fill that gap on a permanent basis
thank you ms jack can i imagine we're
not the only ones in this situation
are there discussions in
in the fatah further discussions in
fataf on this
financial action task course
i'm afraid ms jack is frozen
excuse me
yes i know
that you talked with you're going to
talk with our colleagues
with the fataf and perhaps i've got a
colleague online that can
add something but we do participate in
these famous fataf meetings and we
always want to try and improve the
measures that are currently in place
thank you then another point
personally in the comments
that were made by the government when
the emergency emergency order was
adopted the prime minister said
that
that in fact certain activities were not
covered by
the act and that's rather concerning so
can you talk about some of these gaps
and what needs to be filled in in the
longer term in terms of gaps i think it
was in terms of the information that was
missing because the uh
crowdfunding platforms and payment
service providers were not included
in the
money laundering the pcmlt fe but now
we've widened the requirement so we
think that now we've got more
information that will be gathered and we
will continue to review the measures
that are in place to see if we can go
even further but we're going to work
very closely with fintrac and of this
and of course there's a link with the
work that's already being carried out
on the notion of the the question of
beneficial ownership because where are
these funds actually going when they're
donated
or rather where did they come from
what's the origin of these funds we're
very concerned about interference from
certain foreign donors so will we now be
able to
see this and try this perhaps it's
question more for fintrac and also for
the industry department i think that the
department that's responsible for this
but we're certainly working with them
and i think that that will also help us
thank you thank you thank you mp chadel
we are moving members to our third round
and in this round we have the
conservatives up for uh for five minutes
it's me correct chair
hey lawrence yes i'm ready to go um
thank you yeah thank you thank you very
much
my questions will once again be for the
department of finance um and i want to
talk about in the proclamation
sub
sub b
uh or sorry sub c sorry my apologies um
so
uh in there it gives you the
authorization
or gives the government to regulate
uh property including any crowd
crowd funding or payment processing has
that been done or will that be done
i apologize it has been done via the uh
order but we're also looking at taking
measures to do it on a permanent
fashion
okay you would need additional
legislation though to do that
permanently correct
yes we can do it via legislation and or
regulation
okay and
so but that would have stopped
i guess regulation uh so that's an
ongoing as you're continuing to
look to pursue okay thank you um and
then
so
but the moment that the emergency
measures act is revoked then that would
be
completed right
you have to stop right
okay we have to stop it unless we have
other measures in place at that time yes
and then the second part of sub c is to
require financial services to provide to
determine whether they have position and
control of property that belongs to
persons participating in the blockade
that relates to the freezing of bank
accounts if i'm not mistaken you've said
that you've stopped you've stopped
giving information to have the banks
freeze bank accounts and in the process
of unfreezing it so that part of the
emergencies
measures act is no longer required am i
correct
my understanding is that the rscmp who's
responsible for providing that
information that shared information with
the financial uh sector and that they
are in uh unfreezing accounts uh at the
moment yeah so information was here by
the rcmp uh yesterday
uh and i guess they will share
information on an ongoing basis
basically not aware of any uh new
information
uh
with respect to private prohibited
activities that may be ongoing yeah so
so yeah thank you and so so based on
your information with the assemblies
resolving
there is no longer
there's no longer
there's no longer any utilization of
that of that provision and and when we
look at the processing of the fintech
that should really be done by a separate
regulation following a study not just as
an ad hoc of an emergencies act after a
crisis has extended would those be fair
comments or would you disagree
on the first part
to my knowledge the to the extent that
there are no activity prohibited
activity ongoing the unfreezing will
continue if there are new information
provided by the rcmp to which i'm not
privy the order is still in effect so i
i have no knowledge
that uh freezing or is occurring
currently only that accounts are being
unfrozen so so just just
just on that thank you very much in
accordance with your understanding of
the of the proclamation if in fact at a
pipeline there was a gathering or a uh
or a an assembly that was unlawful and
sought to interfere with critical
infrastructure which would be a pipeline
the rcmp could submit information to
financial institutions and have those
bank accounts frozen right now or
anytime this emergencies act is in place
and that correct
i'm not sure that situation would apply
i don't know if my colleague
sam at justice could help as i was not
privy to the creation of the section on
critical infrastructure
thank you very much and thank you for
the question so it's not that all
assemblies are considered unlawful it is
the criteria that is set out actually in
the emergency measures regulations
if you give me a moment to pull those up
um
so the criteria set out there is
um uh
the serious disruption of the movement
of persons or goods or the serious
interference with trade the interference
with the functioning of critical uh
infrastructure or the support of the
threat or use of acts of serious
violence against persons or property so
it would be a factual assessment as to
whether any assembly that would occur
for example thank you very much for that
my time in short the if if if for
example a
environmental activist said they should
blow up uh pipelines and a group of
assembly and they acted in a way that
was unlawful or a weight in trying to
attempt to
break up or like what happened in the
coastal pipeline that could potentially
if there was a group involved their
accounts could be frozen
so i would have to please i would have
to defer to the rcmp in terms of
linkages and assessment on that point
okay thank you
thank you mp lawrence we are now moving
to the liberals for five minutes and uh
ps trackies
thank you mr chair and it's really nice
to be here today once again on the
finance committee and thank you to the
witnesses for your testimonies you've
given us a lot to think about and very
clear answers and it's very much
appreciated
we've talked a lot about the freezing of
bank accounts and i'm just curious it
maybe you miss shock or it might be the
rcmp that's able to provide this
information but i'm curious to know what
safeguards are in place to ensure
the canadians not involved in the
blockades are not mistakenly targeted by
the freezing of bank accounts do you are
you aware of any safeguards that are in
place
well certainly the safeguard that we put
in the legislation is this ongoing
obligation on in
financial institution to review the
information that they have in their
possession
so if somebody was unfortunately
captured which would seem unlikely but
it's possible
uh the person can contact the financial
institution and review uh the
information that they have it could be a
question of mistaking identity
and the the bank in question can
unfreeze the account based on the
information provided if they need
additional information
they could approach uh the rcnp as well
so
in view of the way it's been set up a it
seems unlikely in view of the fact that
you need to use money and you need a you
need proof that it's towards an activity
that is prohibited under section two
i think it gives a very good basis to
ensure that consumers are protected
and i'm also thank you for that and i'm
also very interested in determining the
sources of funding to make sure that you
know we follow the money um and that you
know we protect our financial
institutions and our our democracy so we
know that leaked data suggests that
nearly 41 percent of donations made to
the convoy through give send go
came from the united states
do we have a sense of who these donors
are i'm interested to know like what
types of organizations or individuals
from the u.s are supporting the convoy
and
in your opinion what threat do do such
large foreign donations posed to our
democratic institutions and our national
sovereignty
well i do not have any information or
details as to the i read uh of course uh
the newspaper and understand that there
was a certain amount of money coming
from
other countries i do not have those
numbers certainly to the extent that
that money entered the canadian
financial sector systems
it would be captured if it was used and
provided
a post
after the order came into force will be
captured under the order
uh and that money could be seized
uh as for your broader question uh
in view of the fact i don't have the
information i'm not able to assess to
what extent it has an impact on
on on democracy
and i was wondering miss jacques if you
earlier to my colleague and i think it
was uh to my colleague
mr chambers i could be wrong um
with regard to the gofundme and once the
emergency act was dropped on february 15
or it went into effect february 15th
you know you said that all the money was
returned before emergencies act was
declared
and i know that the gofundme was
suspended as a fundraiser before the
emergencies act was declared
i'm not sure if the funds were
automatically sent back before i just
was wondering if you can clarify that
point for us yes i should clarify it
in the newspaper i know that
what was reported was gofundme decided
to stop taking additional fun and that
they returned the money to the original
senders in their fund
all of this activity occurred prior to
the order being uh in effect
okay and the last thing if i have time
mr chair my colleague mp zerowitz said
that in order to make some of these
changes permanent
it would have to be legislated and you
agreed to that effect i'm just wondering
would making these powers permanent have
any impact on the ability for canadians
to legally donate money uh through
crowdfunding platforms in the future
no no not at all uh and and the the uh
permanent measures that we intend to
take or with respect to
uh and and more in particularly with
respect to the the platforms and the
payment service providers uh
not the part where uh we put in effect
measures to seize and suspend accounts
thank you and that is the time thank you
ps
and we are moving to the block and for
two and a half minutes uh and peace out
marie
thank you cheer
my question will be for
the department of justice and that way
ms jack can have a bit of a break
i'd like to know whether you agree with
the following affirmation maybe on the
10th of february last five days before
the entry into force of the order
ontario obtained an order from the court
to freeze the two main
crowdfunding accounts for the convey on
give send go
and this was an application of the usual
laws and it was carried out as a result
of the normal cooperation agreements
between canada and the us in terms of
financial crimes
are you in agreement with that
affirmation
yes this procedure was carried out under
our provision under the canadian
criminal code yes thank you very much so
what i've understood then
is that the order the emergencies act
does not fill a legal vacuum given that
there was already something in place
now i'd also like to recall
that for the crowdfunding platforms
the securities regulators in the
province and we've got the equivalent in
quebec with the securities regulator and
they already consider them as financial
interpret intermediaries that are
subject to quebec
legislation so i think that there's not
a legal vacuum but perhaps it's more of
an administrative vacuum
the regulators need to get used perhaps
to these
new ways of doing things with the
crowdfunding platforms and here i'd like
to hear from uh ms dixon to see whether
the department of justice is in
agreement with that
well if i could come back to your first
questions where i'm going quickly
and so far as there was a vacuum that
was to be filled it was not all of the
funds that were
given to illegal protests or for illegal
assemblies and then for the second
question i'm going to turn to ms jacques
on the question of
where there may be this so-called
administrative vacuum rather than a
legal one
yes please do go ahead
well as far as we are concerned
in the federal government when we were
looking to see whether there was a
vacuum in terms of ventrac and we tried
to fill in that gap to make sure that
the various entities would actually be
compelled to report certain transactions
that had not been covered in the past
yes that's very clear then thank you so
it was covered from a legal point of
view in the provinces and with the
securities uh regulatory agencies and
there was no federal coverage because
it's not federal jurisdiction now i'm
not aware of what's happening in the
provinces but of course i've taken out
of what you've said yes it's under
provincial competence thank you
thank you mp summary we are moving to uh
mp blakey for two and a half minutes
please
so i think there are canadians who are
concerned um
about
their support for other political causes
and demonstrations
being captured uh under these emergency
measures notwithstanding that these are
meant to be
applied in a you know prescribed limited
time frame and with respect to one you
know particular
uh
event which is the illegal occupation of
ottawa and uh and sympathetic blockades
at border crossings
so one safeguard
that might provide some reassurance to
those folks is the february 15th
date
where any contributions prior to
february 15th are not are not covered
what other reassurances do canadians who
are concerned that their support of
other political causes might implicate
them
in
measures coming out of these emergency
orders
what other reassurances do they have
that this doesn't provide law
enforcement an opportunity
to implicate them in in these measures
well as you mentioned i think that uh
this situation here was prescribed and
you have to fall under the definition of
a
designated person and activities that
are prohibited by section two to five
so of course if people want to donate
for various purposes they wouldn't be
captured by by this extraordinary
measure
now if it was the case the government
required financial institutions to send
a letter uh in the event that an account
is frozen
highlighting that the freezing of that
account is related to these emergency
measures
then the absence of such a letter would
be something that might provide
additional comfort to canadians who are
concerned
that an account freezing might be
connected to these measures is that is
that fair to say
that if there was a notification
protocol that that might help put
people's mind at ease
it's possible that it would but it's
certainly uh not it what is prescribed
by the current uh order
okay i thank you for that
um
part of me
that was my line of questioning so
thank you very much thank you i mean i
think part of partly what i'm driving at
is i'm you know i'm thinking about what
recommendations that we as a committee
can make
in order to try and address some of the
very legitimate concerns that canadians
have
not just about overreach inherent in the
use of the act itself but overreach
beyond what is prescribed within these
orders
and so i think that's an important
component of our oversight work as a
parliamentary committee is to try and
provide recommendations for how
those legitimate concerns can be
addressed which is why i keep coming
back to the idea
of some kind of notification so that
canadians can know
that if they did have an account frozen
that they would know
if it was under the authority of this
order
or not
if not then they know that it's not a
result of this order and if so they have
a document that they can use to then try
and seek remedies in the case that
remedies are warranted
thank you mp blakey uh we are moving now
to the conservatives i i i on my list
i've got mp lawrence i'm not sure if
andrew lawrence if you're up again but
i've got five minutes for the
conservatives
sure i'm i'm good to go again
um um
um so i uh just wanted to uh
to go over i really want to get clarity
um did mp chambers want to go there i
see him on screen are you
you're gonna end up
i i can go philip if you want to go go
ahead there
thank you yeah i recognize that cuts
into my time uh let's just like to pick
up just on the line of my ndp colleague
who i think makes some excellent points
about providing some comfort to
canadians but also some recommendations
we are making precedent
with what's happening right now and i i
worry
when we reference political motives as a
basis for some of the actions um that
are being taken i think future
governments may not be as benevolent and
we should think about that as future
governments or maybe have different
political leanings so i'm very
interested in in considering the actions
we make now and applying them to the
future uh and look as a as a
conservative i'm all for outsourcing or
considering outsourcing parts of of
government actions but we are looking at
outsourcing parts of the judicial system
with zero recourse for individuals
before actions are taken and so i i
fully recognize and appreciate that
these
issues were contemplated
in terms of violations of the charter
but can i get an answer on
if there was a clear violation of
section 8 of the charter will there be
an undertaking to provide this committee
with the judicial opinion under which uh
supported the decision to enact this
process
i can take that question isabella um so
what i can
this isn't a statute where normal
charter statements are actually made
these are indeed regulations made
pursuant to the emergencies act
the assessment that's been done so no
legal opinion would be forthcoming in
normal circumstances
the measures that have been
tailored are the measures put in place
have been tailored to limit any impact
and we all understand that the rights
are protected but no right is is uh
protected um there is a possibility to
reasonably uh limit that right uh that
and that limit has to be of course
proportional to the objective that we
are trying to achieve so in drafting the
legislation what was put in place to
deal with the really unprecedented
events that we were living here in
canada that is the assessment that was
done okay so no judicial opinion will be
forthcoming but i mean i hope you will
have an opinion because this is going to
be before the courts and i i hope that
we've thought through this when we say
that something
that the charter is applicable
but it seems like there's a bit of a
circular argument happening here that it
it is applicable but it's
but it's not really because there's some
limits but i mean that's it that's in
the charter so i'll perhaps move
i can respect that there are gaps in the
current system
and the emergency powers fill those gaps
what i am concerned about is emergency
power is continuing to be invoked for an
indefinite period of time until those
gaps are settled so can we expect uh
regulations forthcoming that are going
to fill these gaps and can we expect
emergency powers to be invoked until
that time
so perhaps i'll start i think we heard
um well i attended a brief yesterday
where ministers mendocino uh and lametty
uh were briefing the senate and the uh
the communication at that point in time
is that the assessment of whether the
emergencies act and the regulations in
order made under it continue to be
necessary and that assessment is being
done on an hourly basis is what i heard
okay so that's that's good thank you
thank you so much so mr chair with my
remaining time i'd like to based on the
testimony we've heard i have a motion i
will put to the floor i have circulated
it to some individuals uh and that reads
as follows that for as long as
emergencies act
financial requirements are in place that
all federal departments and agencies
provide a weekly report to this
committee for the total number of
persons and accounts indicating the type
of account and ownership of the account
they have flagged or requested be frozen
by regulated financial institutions
broken down by department and agency
that all federally regulated financial
agencies provide a similar weekly report
of the total number of persons and
accounts that have been frozen using the
emergency act powers i will forward this
to the clerk
uh for consideration and i would
further note that we're looking at the
gross and net uh
accounts affected so you know every week
it could be 200 but it could be 200
people every week but i i would hope
that this is something this committee
could consider thank you very much
thank you mp chambers
and uh now we're moving to the liberals
and the mp or ps fragiscados for five
minutes and then after uh ps fragascados
uh concludes
to suspend for five minutes as we are in
a three-hour session to give everybody
an opportunity to uh have a bio break or
to stretch their legs thank you a point
of order chair
point of order
point of order um i believe a motion was
uh moved and so i believe that uh we
have to it was not moved there was no no
motion was moved
so if have uh
says the floor just on that same point
of order if i may
mr chair can we just hear maybe from mr
chambers to that effect i i i took his
attention to the motion but
i don't
some clarification from him
thank you mr blakey thank you mr chair
mr chair was my intention to put that
motion to the floor
um i i hope that it would be something
we could deal with expeditiously
i would be willing to uh
you know want to have a break and
discuss but it is on the floor
uh if we want to have the break now i'd
be happy to do that but would hope that
we could uh deal with that motion uh
perhaps on indiana's consent
uh
chair if i could
oh i i think we had our hands off oh
okay i can't i'm sorry julia i can't see
the the hands up on my end
oh that's okay mister uh p mr chair are
you you're happy with i apologize yes i
could not see the uh members of my body
that's okay i think sophie was before me
so i don't mind advice she's got a
comment before before i no no actually
you were first julie
no you no you okay um mr chair
mr chair i uh i i welcome either us
taking the break right now or uh sort of
uh uh since
at least i haven't seen the motion i'd
love to sort of see it before we
actually discuss it move this to the end
since this is an outstanding and
excellent conversation
if that is amenable so either after the
break we start or at the very end my
preference is at the very end because i
think we're actually getting through uh
a lot of information and i'm okay to
discuss this at the end if mr chambers
is amenable even the last 15 minutes i'm
happy to do it
sure uh thank you mp zerowitz mp
chambers uh i
would be open to that just if i could
get clarification that since that mo
this motion is considered to be on the
floor that it will be voted upon before
the end of the meeting then i would be
more than happy to move this to the last
15 minutes of the meeting
any other hands up uh
clerk
yes mr chair just uh
yeah thank you mr chair echoing my
colleague and uh i would like to to read
it before
mr
chamber went very fast and and i'm i
assume we won't we don't have it in
french
that's okay but i would like to
uh to have a bit of time to read it
thank you
any uh
any other hands up yeah share uh from
the floor here in ottawa um yes
fragrance yeah thank you
uh
if i could suggest then if we are in
fact going to leave the uh
leave this motion until the last 15
minutes if we could have a break
right before that so that all members
have uh looked at it have discussed it
that would be helpful as well
it doesn't have to be very long but i
was on mute
yeah and is
clerk again on the floor or can you see
any other hands up there are no more
hands up sir
okay so it's about taking a break to
have the members uh take a look at uh at
the motion
have a
bio break as well as i believe the uh
to have the motion in french is uh
what uh what we are looking for
and just want to see how the members if
you can just uh
scan the room and the uh
and your your uh zoom uh clerk please
there's ms
derowitz
and peter
mr chair just to confirm it is in french
i have uh sent it to the clerk i have
also sent it to my colleagues uh mr
francis gatos as well as miss chatel and
i believe miss uh zurwich would also
have it in her
uh p9 account as well uh and i
as i said i i would be oh i don't know
the rules here so just look for
clarification
um that this motion is on the floor
would definitely agree to putting it at
the end of the meeting
subject to confirmation that a vote will
be held on this motion
during this meeting
so if my colleagues can
agree to that i would be more than happy
to uh discussion discuss
um
yes i cannot see you but if
it's okay i'm giving you double piece mr
chair um so just uh just a couple of
comments one is um i think what we're
agreeing is because we're at halftime
we're doing a a five minute break then
we're coming back and hopefully we'll
continue the discussion because we're
getting excellent information then we'll
stop at 15 minutes uh prior to the end
and i think we're going to take
a five minute break at that point to uh
uh to sort of just pause to sort of make
sure that we're all on track with the
with the emotion in terms of within
ourselves and have reviewed it uh and
then i think we're gonna come back and
debate it until there is a vote
uh and so uh if that's uh i'm in
agreement with uh with that
and i hope that uh
that is uh that is good for everyone
else
thank you for encapsulating everything
and pete zerowitz
[Music]
empty chambers
uh in the interest of compromise i'll
i'll i would
agree to the five minute break now but i
i will i wouldn't recommend we have an
additional five minute break at the end
of the meeting but i think we could do
the five minute break now and and i'd
like to save some time in case there is
some discussion that we need about this
motion
because i am open to amendments but i
would like to make sure that we get this
dealt with expeditiously
okay any other uh discussion any uh
hands miss chatelle has her hand up
mp chatel mr mr chair yes i think uh
just uh
uh welcoming the the spirit of um
of of compromi compromising an amendment
and thank you again for the wonderful
translation thank you i received it
about french and english
okay merci mp chateau
thank you mp chatel
clerk again i look to you
there is no more hands up
no more hands up okay so uh we will uh
suspend at uh at this time we'll take a
uh five minutes or so and we'll see the
members back in about five-ish minutes
thank you
and members yet will so we
went to the motion at about 5 15
witnesses uh today and i've got mr
fragiskados up now for five minutes
thanks uh thank you very much mr chair
and thank you to the witnesses
before i ask my questions i think it's
important to put
where we're at
in a general context mr chair
my colleague mr chambers just spoke and
i don't know him very well actually i
don't know him at all but
he uh he has a very good reputation
on our side of the bench he's seen as
someone who's reasonable and thoughtful
and the the few committee meetings here
at finance that i participated in
he has been uh he has been just that but
uh i'm gonna have to disagree with one
of the things that he said and it's
pretty serious thing
uh to to disagree on
and that is the the motives of the
government when he
just spoke he's talked about the
government acting here
based on political motives
rather than substantive concerns about
the security of the country and
and the residents of of ottawa what
we've seen in the past few weeks
is
should be horrific to to all of us i
hope it is but for some reason i think
when i look across the aisle sometimes
it's maybe not and that's a deep concern
i think that when you have an entire
city that's been the capital city of
this country no less
laid under siege
neighborhoods blocked off people unable
to get to work seniors unable to get
groceries
families unable to take their kids to
school and not unable to get to work
themselves
that is an enormous concern and when our
borders are blockaded that is a serious
concern also about
the sovereignty and
security of the country at large not to
mention the fact that the organizers of
this convoy
were calling for no less than the
overthrow of a democratically elected
government
each of those points relates directly to
the act
because
their existence
indicates
that the invocation of the emergencies
act was indeed just
was indeed the right thing to do this
was a public order emergency
i would hope that we can
if we're going to disagree on things as
we as we naturally will i would hope
that we agree on the
security of the country and the need to
to do anything and everything we can
to ensure
that
convoy organizers like pat king for
example
are not allowed to set the narrative on
this and i still think that there are
colleagues across the aisle in the
conservative party
that uh
maybe we can find a way to to agree on
maybe we can find
a way to uh
uh to realize uh moderation and and work
with them
uh even point of order disagreements on
this point of view
it was the last point uh phil if you uh
if you want to raise a point of order
you can clean the border
i i think this member has several times
pointed out relevance and i really do
wonder what his soliloquy had anything
to do with the financial matters
respecting the emergency act but he's
completed so
yeah it's it's not a soliloquy to raise
these concerns about the security of the
country in any case though i do want to
ask
the officials and i'll ask it to the
department to finance and justice as we
know
the
the emergencies act takes very seriously
the charter of rights in fact the
charter still reigns supreme it is still
the supreme law of the land
and i just want to know from finance
officials and and justice officials what
that means in terms of their
interpretation of the act in terms of
their work and their departments
where does the charter fit and how does
it all
how does it all work how does it how
does it come together in the end to
work as a
as just that the supreme law
even when we haven't the emergencies act
invoked
go ahead
perhaps samantha from justice perhaps i
might start and my colleague isabel can
follow up i would offer
so then the war measures act which was
in place and was replaced by the
emergencies act didn't contain the
express
uh provision indicating that the charter
of rights and freedoms applies
notwithstanding the invocation of an
emergency but i think as we all know the
charter of rights and freedoms applies
to all governmental action from the
creation of statutes regulations
all the way through to its
implementation and so the assessment of
whether a governmental action complies
with the charter of rights is an ongoing
i would offer daily occurrence for for
all government officials the emergencies
act makes it explicit because of its
predecessor but it doesn't actually
change how we do business and so all of
the measures throughout both the
emergency measures regulations and the
emergency economic measures order were
were drafted with the charter of rights
in mind and to the extent any right has
been limited in any way it was done with
respect to either the section 7 analysis
or with respect to section 1 and the
proportionality to achieve the objective
that was sought
to deal with the unprecedented events
thank you and thank you
mp frag escados we are moving to our
fourth round
and i've got the uh the conservatives up
i do have mp chambers i'm not sure if
that uh that is still the same list but
uh mp chambers up for five
minutes uh
mr clerk i'll or mr chair i'd pass my
time to uh mr stewart if he has
questions
if not uh
well why don't i ask one and i can i can
split my time with mr stewart if he's
ready um
are there so question for justice
officials
are there
other laws and statutes that allow
for the bank accounts of individuals to
be frozen
um
i believe the statute administered by
fintroc would allow some freezing but i
will offer um pass the floor to my
colleague isabel on in the financial
sector
yes i know the the uh the legislation
the fintrac legislation
does not allow for the freezing uh but
certainly on an ongoing basis as you may
know uh police forces doing
investigation when there are illegal
activities uh certainly deal with
financial institutions and accounts are
frozen
on an ongoing basis of their
irregularities fraud theft
okay so perhaps a more finer point
there are other avenues through which
individuals may have their accounts
frozen
correct
currently yes that is correct there are
other avenues for but not that would
cover the specific events that required
uh the emergencies act to be activated
okay i mean the provincial government
had accounts frozen
without using the emergency measures act
so is it the position is it the judicial
opinion
of the individuals here or the
government that there was no other
way to freeze an individual's account
other than invoking the emergencies act
well uh i i will leave uh some entire
speak to the the the legal uh
views but certainly it's not that we the
the federal government thought there was
no other venues to freeze the accounts
there's no other venues to freeze
accounts in view of the current
illegal blockades that were ongoing and
the fact that we had to take extreme
measures
to freeze the accounts to basically
discourage people
to fund to fund illegal activities
i mean that's that's an interesting
answer i hope we'll get some clarity on
that i suspect we will i mean one of the
issues with the emergencies act is that
there are no other avenues the
government could have taken so that's an
interesting um an interesting response i
will i will yield my time to my
colleague mr
uh mr lawrence for the remainder
thank you thank you very much and i i
just wanted to uh to get some clarity uh
or just to um
so
just so canadians can understand and i
can't be the only mp in fact i know in
our caucus it's almost throughout the
received many many phone calls and many
emails with very very concerned and
scared canadians and so
um
let's if we can provide some clarity so
you've you've already filled in some
spaces and i want to fill in the rest so
if in fact you supported the convoy or
you were present at the at the protest
uh from february 15th to february 22nd
there is a
there is a possibility your account
could be frozen but if you made a
financial support or any other type of
sort or were even present
at the at the
um at the protest in ottawa before 15th
your bank accounts couldn't have been
shouldn't be frozen is that correct
prior to february 15th should not have
been frozen that is correct
so it's it's it's
really just individuals who supported or
were present in in the ottawa protest
between february 15th and february 22nd
that should be concerned
those were the ones that were involved
in those activities that are prohibited
by section two of the regulation that is
correct okay and so because we've
stopped freezing bank accounts anyone
whose account has not been frozen we can
say that it will not be is that correct
it will not be frozen to the extent that
they do not start funding other illegal
activities that are prohibited by
section two
to five of the uh emergency measures
regulations
to your knowledge are there any of those
activities going on right now
not to my knowledge but i i believe the
rcmp would be a better place than me to
have that information i do not and i
just want to follow up with my comments
from mr blakey is there anything
stopping you from asking the financial
institutions to send
to sending notices out to people of
their accounts frozen from emergency act
uh is there there's because i don't
believe there is i'm a lawyer i don't
think there's anything
asking them because there are i can't
tell you how many canadians i had an 80
year old gentleman call me and say i'm
not sure if i'm going to be able to eat
tomorrow because my account might be
frozen because i gave 50 bucks to the
convoy when it was legal
they're terrified out there there's got
to be something you and your department
can do to alleviate this fear well i
think very short answer please
it's certainly something that that we we
should consider uh but thank thank you
for uh offering that suggestion
okay thank you mp lawrence at the time
and we are moving to the liberals and
pete zerowitz for five minutes
uh thank you so much mr chair and i want
to thank i want to thank all our
witnesses for for their longevity
and for uh being so patient with
answering all of our questions i want to
just dispel a couple of things just
because i think it's important too i
believe that one of my conservative
colleagues earlier said that there was a
complete sense a suspension of civil
liberties and so i just want to make
sure that everybody is very clear that
the enactment of the emergencies act
requires that the actions are undertaken
under our public order emergency to be
charter compliant every step of the way
and we have had that confirmed at this
meeting i think there's also been and i
think that mr lawrence was a little bit
on this track that um little old ladies
and sort of the general public uh are
being impacted
and so uh in terms of their accounts
being frozen and i just want to make
sure that i read into the record
something from an article that the mail
had had written and it said the rcmp
banking sector and federal government
said monday that account freezing powers
bestowed bestowed under the emergencies
act to help authorities deal with the
convoy protests do not affect donors to
the protest despite unsubstantiated
claims by a conservative mp that a
constituent had her bank account frozen
over a 50 contribution at no time did we
provide a list of donors to financial
institutions the rcmp said in a
statement monday the agency said that
while it had sent financial institutions
a list of accounts to monitor and freeze
those accounts belong to individuals in
companies suspected of involvement in
illegal acts such as influencers in the
illegal protest in ottawa and vehicle
owners and drivers who did not want to
leave the area impacted by the protest i
just want to make sure that we have that
on record i do not want anybody out
there being terrified uh that their
accounts are about to be frozen or that
there's all these canadians who have
just their accounts willy-nilly and uh
frozen so important to put that on the
record
i also think it's important to state uh
the following and this is from a speech
from um
from our deputy prime minister
administer finance she had indicated a
federal fight government institutions
will have new broad authority to share
us relevant information with banks and
other financial service providers to
ensure that we can all work together to
put a stop to the funding of these
illegal blockades this is about
following the money this is about
stopping the financing of these illegal
blockades
um and today she says we are serving
notice um she says the canadian economy
needs um them so them being sort of uh
all of those that were uh involved in
the blockade uh to be doing legitimate
work not to be illegally making us all
poor uh we also heard excellent uh
responses um from ms jacques today that
has clarified that we did have gaps in
terms of the fact that fintrac and the
rcmp were not able to
uh
sort of uh collect uh data from uh both
um
uh uh the crowdsource uh platforms
crowdfunding platforms as well as
cryptocurrencies um we have also
indicated that we're going to be
introducing legislation to make this
permanent
we've also
heard that federal government is not
personally collecting the data it is
that we've enabled that information to
actually go directly to financial
institutions and rcmp for them to take
actions
and so i just want to make sure that we
put that all on record it's important
for us all to be clear about where uh we
are at
um and so my question uh my first
question is actually
uh to follow along the the lines of uh
mr francisco
mr fragiskados after his soliloquy when
he uh talked about confirming the
compliance of the emergencies act uh and
public uh order emergency uh to be
compliant with the charter i wonder if i
could um have uh ms dixon talk to
the the other key difference which is
that there are accountability measures
uh that the emergency act imposes and
can you maybe describe some of these
please
um absolutely thank you very much so
specifically with respect to the order
and the regulations themselves
the emergencies act provides that
members of both houses of parliament can
actually move motions forward so to the
extent there was a desire to see
amendments made that is a possibility
that is enabled by the act itself
further there's a parliamentary review
committee that is established and has
some timelines to do certain things i
won't take up your time with the
specifics it is set out in section 62 of
the emergencies act itself and then
finally when the emergency would be
revoked or
expired there is an inquiry that needs
to be put in place
that will look into the circumstances
that led to uh the emergency being
declared and the response
thank you and thank you mp zorowitz uh
that's the time uh we are moving now to
the block and mostly
for uh two and a half minutes
thank you cheer
my questions are for the department of
justice
ms measlyn dixon or her colleagues
when we look at ordinary laws we've got
the criminal
code and we've got the act
on proceeds of crime and terrorist
financing
which ban
financial crimes and money laundering
are the funding of criminal activities
so according to you
do you believe that the regular laws
allow us
to prevent direct or indirect funding of
an illegal activity that's the question
the regulation that's been set up
specifies what we mean when we refer to
an illegal assembly that would be
considered to be criminal in nature so
we've made this more uh precise and so
there are links with offenses that has
now been made very clear for canadians
so basically you're saying that the
rules that are in place the municipal
rules and the criminal code
and the highway code did not recognize
the
occupation in ottawa as an illegal
activity no that's not what i said sorry
what i was specifying was that there
were specific details that were added in
terms of what would be considered to be
an illegal assembly with a very specific
well-defined criteria in section two of
the regulation and according to the
department of justice
with the regular laws would it
be possible
to
indicate that the occupation in ottawa
was a criminal activity
there were certain elements no doubt but
when the declaration took place the
government
examined what they were faced with and
took the necessary measures to put a
stop to that
so i'm going to try and put my question
again before the 15th of february the
occupation of ottawa could not be
perceived as an illegal activity
the
necessary measures to prevent that had
not been taken and so there were
emergency measures that were implemented
and they were considered to be necessary
well it seems that we're trying to avoid
the question the occupation of ottawa
with the regular laws in place it could
they be perceived as
an illegal criminal activity yes or no
yes there were certain elements that
were attached to crime thank you very
much
that's the the time mp summary and we
are moving to the ndp mp blakey for two
and a half minutes
thank you so we know that a number of uh
donor names were revealed due to an
anonymous hack and they were posted
online
would that
be sufficient uh under the order for
financial institutions if they received
that information or if they
you know staff
of a financial institution saw those
names uh leaked would that be sufficient
under the order
to create a duty for them to freeze
accounts or
would they
or or not i guess is the question would
they have to consult law enforcement uh
first in order to get an adequate
determination as to whether or not
people were
actively supporting that convoy beyond
the content of that of the hack
i must admit i'm not aware of the of the
release of uh that that hack that you're
referring to but what i can tell you is
financial institutions
were very concerned to actually take the
proper steps to satisfy themselves that
the people
uh if they took the decision to freeze
their account uh
would be people
that were designated persons and that
they were involved in illegal activities
so i think they would just on the face
of the names i would doubt but i cannot
speak for them that they would just take
action i think they would need to
satisfy themselves and again i'm sure
they would consult their legal team to
ensure that they meet uh the requirement
of the order prior to taking action has
there been any direction or counsel
given by government to financial
institutions as to
what kind of information
they can retain or should retain or
whether they should destroy information
or how they should treat people on a on
a go forward basis after the resolution
of the emergency that precipitated
uh the use of the act
i've not had such discussions i mean the
information that was provided pursuant
to the order
was prescribed by the order
information was shared between
maybe law enforcement and the financial
entities and the i'm sure they will
abide in accordance with uh
laws that are in place with respect to
retention of any information they may
have but i get your opinion both as to
whether it's possible and whether it's
advisable for government to issue any
such
direction including whether there'd be
some legislative action required
to give a clear
expectation to financial institutions as
to how
they should treat the information that
they may have received from law
enforcement or elsewhere and what they
should do with information on people's
files so that it it would not affect
people on a go-forward basis in terms of
their
their
you know personal financial
business
short answer please
certainly a question i would like to
take back and consult with uh our
department of justice
could you once you've done that could
you then give us a response in writing
to that question to the committee please
i i can consider the question yes and
see what response we can provide
yes thank you
thank you thank you mp blakey we are
moving to the conservatives and peace to
work for uh five minutes
i think uh uh mr chairman p stewart's
having some technical difficulties so
we'll just do a little bit of uh
uh
tag team here uh so i'll
that's okay thank you very much mr chair
um
i
fully recognize that we're in a bit
unprecedented times on a whole host i
mean it's a very overused words but you
know the first time we're working
through this legislation
um it would be very helpful for the
committee as we're as we're discussing
or contemplating any recommendations or
future
uh uses of
kind of either process map or flowchart
at a very high level that that
discusses or outlines
the flow of information
between
the
rcmp or other sources of information
before it gets to a financial
institution
so that we can understand you know where
who touches certain information where it
ends up and then where decisions are
being done i think we've had some great
information today from our officials in
terms of you know the banks are making
these determinations based on some
information provided from the rcmp but
it would be
if this was documented perhaps in
written form i think would would
certainly help us
uh or help me as a member of the
committee and i hope others
as we consider any recommendations about
process going forward is that something
we could ask of our officials
certainly on the sharing of information
that is shared by the rcmp
with the financial institution that
would be best place to to map this out
but we can um you know certainly consult
that would be fine too just to the best
of your knowledge how does at a high
level you know something gets flagged it
moves over you know how it kind of goes
through the process and ends up with a
financial institution i hope we'll have
opportunities i suspect we'll have
opportunities to hear from the financial
institution themselves in terms of their
own internal processes but with respect
to the government that would be very
helpful um yes that is a good point
because they also have their internal
processes uh
yeah and they rely on those to also uh
obtain information that was helpful for
this order yes these algorithms that uh
are a bit of a black box and i'm sure
we'll learn more about those as well
that we don't have any line of sight
into
the minister of finance today stated and
this is a quote as of today
a bank or financial service provider
will be able to immediately freeze their
suspended account without a court order
um
implying that i think this can happen in
previous times with a corridor which
allows for
individuals to make representations on
their behalf the uh executive director
of the canadian constitution foundation
has written
that this sounds like an invitation
for banks to arbitrarily seize property
of suspected involvement without any
built in recourse or ability to apply
for reconsideration the testimony we've
heard today
from uh these witnesses and thank you
very much for being forthcoming
is that there is the possibility for
reconsideration after the fact is i just
would like to confirm if that's your
understanding
it is my understanding if an account is
frozen and the person uh finds out of
course realize the account is frozen
that they can and get in touch with the
financial institution and as we explain
there is a duty to determine on an
ongoing basis so that the financial
institutions have to review on an
ongoing basis the situation and address
it so
the
the nature of the uh
suspension or freezing of the account
is a temporary right this is an extreme
measure and can be as we've found out
these accounts can be on on frozen
fairly rapidly
thank you
thank you for determination thank you so
two quick questions and that is
is this does this end up like a no-fly
list where somebody's now asterisks for
the rest of their life and then second
question follow-up would be
for those accounts that have been frozen
are these accounts that are limited to
the individuals under investigation i'm
thinking of circumstances where there
are a number of say joint accounts or
perhaps someone's a power of attorney
for you know their parents accounts and
all of a sudden because of one
individual uh who has uh been sub
is it now possible for these other
individuals to have their accounts and
financial services impacted
yeah i would say it's quite different
than the passenger protect uh program
that
that was in place
which has you know different processes
uh this is temporary extraordinary under
the uh an order under the uh emergencies
act
uh and can be
revoked and changed
fairly quickly um with respect to
accounts i mean a number of accounts can
be affected including joint accounts
with respect to those for which i have
that that's okay yeah thank you mp
chambers that's uh that is the time and
and now we are moving to the liberals
and uh mpd and welcome to the committee
thank you very much this has been a
fascinating afternoon
uh witnesses thank you very much for the
opportunity to hear from all of you
what we've gone through the last few
weeks
for me personally
has been a shock to my system
and i can say it's
you know a shock to many people
people who witnessed it
i've got a couple of questions but i
just want to finish off what where we
where you started madame jacques uh
on the
one point is i think we talked about 200
plus bank accounts that were frozen
out of
i forget how many thousands of uh
dollar donors you and uh how many donors
was that i mean i believe it was in the
globe and mail is or something like that
but
uh if there's overreach one would assume
well i don't know i don't want to put
words in your mouth but
did you say it was 200 and some over all
of canada over the thousands and
thousands of people that we saw
uh
illegally protesting blockading whatever
that were frozen out of how many dollars
amounts and
two is
you know my heart goes out to anybody
that really thinks that you know if they
put twenty dollars or fifty dollars or
you know in good faith
uh
to a good cause that they could be
somehow held liable and um and and you
really are reassuring me and hearing you
in the last couple of hours that that is
not the case if erroneously it happens
it could
it should and could and would
definitely be overturned uh
by simply contacting the bank uh you
know and taking care of that i practiced
law it's been out about 10 years since
i've not practiced law but before that i
practiced over 20 years and i know
certainly in matrimonial law
all kinds of frozen bank accounts
happened there so you know uh you know
there's all kinds of situations where
you know they get frozen and so on and
there is a mechanism if there's an error
or so on but can you go back to that
point again and just reassure us one
more time please
so that these you know these
people that in good faith did something
good across the country uh to really
help
um you know something that they thought
was the right thing to do that they're
not caught in and specifically from what
time frame you know would that have
taken into effect
now if people in good faith were making
donations prior to you know knowing that
the order was in effect and prior to the
situation degenerating to the point that
it did certainly they were not captured
because there's no retroactivity as you
point out to the order
and it was only from a point forward
from february 15th
and
certainly in our all i can say uh in our
discussion with financial entities that
we had in the past week certainly that
was not the target of the activities
certainly not the target of the list
provided by the rcmp
uh
is it possible that somebody was
captured
it's always possible because the order
provides for it but i doubt
uh
that we'd have many of those cases and
to go back to the numbers that you're
asking about
you know i mean the numbers change all
the time and i'm sure they're lower
today than they though those that i the
last ones i have as accounts have been
uh unfrozen on an ongoing basis since
yesterday but the last number i had was
over 206 accounts but you know it's it's
a smaller number of peak people because
some of these people persons have more
than one account
and the total number the value was the
last number i had was seven point eight
million dollars
right
moment for whatever time i have left
i heard a lot and i heard a lot all the
debates most of them whether i was
actually supposed you know whether i was
i was virtual thank god for that but i
heard a lot of them and a lot of the
debates also concentrated on this
predecessor
or or the so-called predecessor to the
act
can can please justice officials
please you know and plain language plain
i would say english in the translation
will be in plain french
the the differences between the
predecessor war measures act which dealt
with war and and military and so on and
i come from you know a place in the
world where i see military
uh and uh you know unfortunately but and
and and the current act please and and
the relation of that to uh our charter
and and you know what rights do we have
as individuals
um and just uh differentiate that or
make similarities please
in a short answer please
very very shortly so the emergencies act
passed in 1988 the charter came into
force in 1982 it applies so any
governmental action be it the statute
the regulation the implementation
implementation must be compliant with
the charter the war measures act was a
different statute and to be very
explicit about it the emergencies act uh
included a
specific reference to the fact that the
charter of rights and freedoms would
apply
thank you and uh so mpd up and members
we are moving to our fifth round this
round will will be our our final round
where we will uh conclude with uh with
the witnesses uh for today and i'm going
to devise as i normally do when we come
to this time and i look at how much time
we have left i will divide up this round
equally amongst the different parties so
it'll be three and a half minutes for
each party it'll start with the the
conservatives and uh
i don't have here who's speaking first
for the conspiracy or who's on the list
so if you can help me out
thanks uh thanks very much uh is mr
mclean did you want to take the round
there sorry i know you've just arrived
greg
no worries yes i would like to eat
around i hope i'm not asking questions
that were previously answered but
um and i apologize for not being here
for the previous session but yes if i
could that would be uh
worthwhile uh may i start
okay
the questions i have i mean i i look at
this this nature
and i'm glad you brought up the charter
on this but the whole nature of actually
expropriating or freezing somebody's
bank account is effectively shutting
them out of
their ability to transact in society uh
and you know going friends and families
and effectively getting help that way is
that you you don't think that's an
overstep of what the charter provisions
are as far as um you know freedom to
transact being one of one of our
fundamental freedoms
so
if i may isabel
the measures have been tailored to limit
the impact on the charter rights no more
than reasonably necessary to end the
unlawful assembly
and the obligation to freeze accounts
only applies to people who are
participating in the illegal activities
that are described in sections two to
five of the emergency measures
regulation and a person can regain
access to their assets by stopping their
participation in those unlawful
activities yeah but it doesn't say how
and it doesn't say in the description
about being involved is rather broad if
you look at it so it could be anybody
that as we say gave 50 bucks to their
son to go and uh you know protest his is
is that not so
uh so i might pass the floor back to my
colleague isabel it was effective as of
the date the regulation was made so as
of the 15th of february anything that
occurred prior to that date is not
captured there's no retroactivity to
this regulation at all so of the two so
i'll go back to isabel then uh pardon me
the so the 206 accounts we're talking
about here were all money that gave or
all funders
canadians that gave funds through gifts
and go after february 15th
i don't know through which means that
they gave money but certainly money that
was uh in the possession of the
financial institutions covered by the uh
the order after february 15th that is
correct
and we were discussing so so
sorry i'm i'm
i don't know if the feed is bad on my
end or at
the other end
no it's just going to say that in
previous discussions that we've had
throughout this meeting what we were
saying is in view of the information
that has been shared by the rcmp
and the view the fact that the the goal
was to stop uh unlawful
funding illegal blockades the unlawful
assemblies
it would occur it would seem
rather rare if somebody had been a given
twenty dollars and would be captured by
uh
or would have an account seized in
that is the way it's written then it's
very possible but what we discussed is
that the the
main purpose and goal was to ensure that
we'd stop the funding for the illegal
blockades it is certainly possible thank
you i appreciate that thank you mp
mclean i appreciate